what's up Brooklyn the reason I love
Twitter so much as i can use twitter
search and listen to people and then
engage and then when they reply back i
can reply back and we start forming
something deeper than what everybody is
defaulted into unfortunately 2015 which
is content push out by this friggin rare
toy it's 999 buy it now right like if i
make great gifts on tumblr like put out
great pictures on Instagram i put up
good videos on youtube or hustle your
work out that your drive is not
predicated on your zip code if I make
funny snaps that I draw on top of these
things will lead to impressions and
people becoming aware of me and coming
into my funnel but then what do you do
with that once they're there thanks so
much Joseph we welcome Damian no worries
creative 7 Alex what uh what's up it's
the people that really understand what
to do with them next are going to win
right isn't that what it's all about
don't you just want to be acknowledged
what is a wink from your favorite
basketball player matter that becomes
retention you get a motion and that's
what it's about that extra effort I
appreciate you Richard Andy you are
fantastic tell him JD always Chris till
the end mmm ye appreciate you listening
7 big time thanks brother Ryan that's
super nice man I hope you enjoyed your
day it's a good looking crew Armando
thanks for sharing that article
appreciate it
you too wish by now cuz they're going
fast SuperBass Big Ups 7 like a
touchdown after the extra point Sarah
that makes complete sense to me
surfboard surfboard